>>Meng: Good afternoon my friends. Our guest
today is Chip Conley, someone I'm honored
to call my friend. Chip is the founder and
CEO and now Executive Chairman of Joie de
Vivre, I hope I pronounced it correctly. [chuckles]
Chinese, yeah Chinese guy you know. [chuckles]
California's largest boutique hotel company.
But Chip is no ordinary CEO. He combines brilliance
with wisdom and compassion in his work. Gavin
Newsom, the Lieutenant Governor of California
calls Chip "that rare breed of CEO who possesses
both a brilliant business mind and a very
big heart. He's a true role model for anyone
who wants to lead." And that's what Gavin
says about Chip.
Chip started his company in 1987 at the age
of 26 with no industry experience. He turned
a seedy motel into a world renowned hotel
that catered to celebrities such as David
Bowie. And Chip focuses on the higher human
needs of his employees, customers, and investors.
His company now consists of over 40 unique
and award winning hotels and spas and restaurants,
employing over 3,000 people. It has been named
the second best place to work in the San Francisco
Bay area -- I wonder what number one is? [laughs]
[laughter]
with employee turnover rate at one-third the
industry average. Chip has also been honored
with top hospitality industry awards and in
2007, he was named the Bay Area's most innovative
CEO.
And my friends please give a warm welcome
to Chip Conley.
[applause]
>>Chip Conley: [clears throat]
[sound of papers shuffling]
What Meng didn't tell you is that he and I
are going down to the Esalen Institute next
week to be involved in a Conscious Capitalism
Conference that John Mackey from Whole Foods
Markets is putting on, the guy that founded
and CEO. So we're gonna be hangin' out naked
in the natural hot springs overlooking the
water next week so I figured I tell ya that.
[laughs] I'm going to very transparent today.
[laughter]
For those of you who were thinking you are
coming to a business lecture, let me set you
straight. This is a psychology lecture today
so I'm gonna actually, oh she's excited [laughs].
It's gonna be a combination of business and
psychology because frankly, from my perspective,
the most neglected fact in business is that
we're all human. And so one of the things
I've learned in the 24 years that I have had
my company, I went to Stanford undergrad,
I went directly into Stanford Business School,
graduated at age 23 from the Stanford Business
School and started my company about two or
three years later.
But 24 years [laughs] into doing this, the
number one thing I've learned about business
is that if you wanna be successful in business
in the long run, especially the higher you
go up in the organization, the more you really
have to understand humans. And yet we have
operating manuals for our computers and our
cars and our, for those who still use them,
our VCR's [chuckles] but we aren't really
issued an operating manual for humans.
What I'm gonna talk about today is my operating
manual for humans in the context of work and
I hope you'll enjoy it. So let's get started.
And I'm gonna start philosophically by saying
that I actually believe that life and business
is all about where you pay your attention.
If you look at the wisdom traditions of the
religious, well known religious traditions,
spiritual traditions, quite often what they
speak to is the idea of where are you paying
your attention?
You're gonna see a lot of pyramids today and
this is not in solidarity with Egypt -- this
is actually [laughs]-- the pyramids are really
in solidarity with Abraham Maslow's hierarchy
of needs which is a theory of human psychology
and the human condition.
And you'll see that as I talk about the idea
of where we are on the pyramid, a lot of it
will come back to where are you paying your
attention on the pyramid. So as you hear my
talk today and, as we have a conversation,
there'll be a lot of time for questions and
answers at the end, I really want you to think
about that is where are you paying your attention
on the pyramid?
This is three different people having three
different kinds of days. I don't know which
kind a day you're having today. How many of
you are having that kind of day? Anybody having
that kind of day? Okay, good, well few of
you. And then that's another guy in the middle
and then there's the woman at the top who's
having, Meng has those days every day. I don't
know how he does it.
But the fact is that in the course of any
one day, you may be anywhere on this pyramid.
In the course of an hour you may toggle up
and down this pyramid. But I think that's
true of companies too.
This is three companies in an industry that
is very troubled, [chuckles] has always been
troubled. The airline industry seems to just
toggle between success and failure pretty
quickly. One of these three companies has
been at the top of their game for 40 years,
Southwest Airlines. The other two are frankly
now combined. This is an old slide before
they actually had their merger.
But what is true of people, what is true of
us in terms of where we fit on this pyramid
is true of companies because guess what -- companies
are full of people. So each of us in our work
has one of three relationships with our work
and there's really only three choices and
this is them. You either have a job, a career,
or a calling. But putting them in the context
of a pyramid helps us to understand how few
of us, frankly, in the course of our work,
are living a calling.
And there's statistical evidence to show that
in fact about 60 to 70 percent of Americans
think of their work as a job. In the last
chapter of the book, Chapter 14, there's actually
a 15 question test you can take to understand
whether you have a job, a career, or a calling.
But about 60 to 70 percent of Americans actually
think of their work as a job. About 20 to
30 percent think of their work as a career
and about, depending upon how you look at
it, five to ten percent, five to fifteen percent
think of it as a calling.
I'll come back to this. But what -- I wanna
tell you a quick story related to this because
one of my basic premises about leadership
and about psychology in business comes from
the idea that the best companies out there
and the best leaders out there help their
employees move up this pyramid.
So I was taking a flight from, let's see where
was I, I was in Austin, Texas, I was actually
at this Conscious Capitalism Conference in
Austin that John Mackey had put on in November
of 2008 and I was flying to Dallas and I was
flying on Southwest Airlines. And there was
a guy handing out peanuts and he was not a
flight attendant, handing out peanuts to everybody
on the plane. And I looked at him like, "Who
is this guy? Why would he be doing that?"
And then I looked at my Southwest Spirit Magazine
and I saw that is the CEO of the company.
It's not Herb Kelleher who was the sort of
famous CEO of Southwest for 37 years, he's
retired. It was a guy named Gary Kelly who's
the relatively new CEO of Southwest handing
out peanuts.
He gets to the back of the plane and I corner
him because no one's talking to him and so
I say -- and our company Joie de Vivre has
had a long history with Southwest doing marketing
together -- so I said to him, this is November
of 2008 and if you'll remember, in 2008, the
first half of 2008, three years ago, there
was a robust worldwide economy. I know that
sounds amazing. I mean it wasn't that long
ago. And part of the reason we know it was
robust was because fuel prices and gas prices
skyrocketed. In fact, in the summer of 2008,
the Presidential election, it was an issue,
the fact that gas prices were as high as they
were. Well, with jet fuel prices going up
in the summer of 2008, most of the airlines
in America started charging for things that
they didn't use to charge for. Like what?
>>voice in audience: [inaudible]
>>Chip Conley: Bags, luggage. What else?
>>male #1: Meals.
>>Chip Conley: Meals, blankets, pillows, headphones.
What's that?
>>male #2: Oxygen.
>>Chip Conley: Oxygen. Well actually getting
to basic needs, there was an airline in Europe,
Ryanair, that actually came that close to
starting to charge for the bathrooms, the
toilets. They were gonna have pay operated
toilets on their plane. They finally got smart
and said, "Okay, let's not charge for that."
Well Southwest Airlines was the only airline
in America that actually chose not to charge
all those extra fees. So I asked him, I asked
the CEO of Southwest while we were on the
plane, "Why is it that you haven't charged?"
And I thought the obvious answer was gonna
be, "Well our customers like our low prices
and we don't wanna upset our customers, and
da, da, da." But instead he gave me a not
obvious answer that relates to this slide.
He pointed to the flight attendants and he
said to me, "Have you ever noticed that the
flight attendants on Southwest are having
a different kind of experience than the flight
attendants on United?" [laughs] I said, "Yes,
in fact I fly out of San Francisco a lot.
It's a United hub. The flight attendants on
United don't look like they're having as good
of a time as your flight attendants." And
he said, "Did you notice things changed after
they started charging for bags and what's
happened in the last few months?" I said,
"Well in the last few months, it feels as
if the flight attendants have become baggage
handlers because we're all now bringing all
of our bags on the plane because we don't
wanna actually be charged for them. And actually
it means that there's this like drill where
we all have to get our bags on the planes
fast because we have to get off the ground
fast." And who's taking the brunt of that
other than us as customers? It's the flight
attendants. And what he said, Gary Kelly,
said to me, he said, "United Airlines when
they made the decision to start charging for
bags gave no thought to what effect that would
have on the flight attendants. We, at Southwest,
when we make decisions one of the most important
things we ask ourselves is 'How is it going
to effect the sense of relationship with work
our key employees are gonna have especially
those that customer facing?'" And then he
said the following, he said, "If we get our
job right what we do is we help our flight
attendants live their calling." Now I'd never
thought of that and for the rest of my flight
I was sort of watching the flight attendants
and saying, "How are they living their calling?"
[laughs]
But his point was this: if you are looking
at creating a long term, sustainable business
model and creating an environment where your
employees are internally inspired by what
they do, you help them move up this pyramid.
We'll come back to it, but it's a really profound
point made by somebody other than me which
made me feel better.
Let me tell you about my calling. I went to
Stanford undergrad, I went to Stanford Business
School, I graduated, I was the youngest guy
in my class graduating from Stanford Business
School, I was very ambitious, I wanted to
go out and like become Mr. Success. And I
worked for Morgan Stanley between my first
and second year of business school in New
York. I didn't like that. I didn't wanna be
an investment banker smoking cigars and wearing
suspenders. That was just not me. And I wanted
to be a real estate developer, I wanted to
do cool sort of progressive real estate development
projects.
And so I decided to take a job out of Stanford
Business School earning $24,000 a year [laughs]
I got paid one-third or one-fourth what the
other jobs were paying me but I really wanted
to work for a developer in San Francisco that
would teach me the business and help me understand
how to do creative real estate development
in San Francisco.
A year into that, at age 24, I realized I
hated what I was doing, [laughs] and I thought
like I was the biggest idiot in my Stanford
Business School class because I didn't take
the big money. I took a job out of Stanford
Business School paying me $2,000 a month.
I was by far the lowest person graduating
out of my class, and I hated what I was doing.
So that's when I actually went down to the
Esalen Institute and I started learning how
to become a massage therapist. I was gonna
be the only Stanford MBA who became a massage
therapist when he grew up, which is not a
bad thing since I found out today from Meng
that you have 200 massage therapists on staff
here. So I maybe could have gotten a job at
Google. [laughs] It's probably the only way
I would get a job at Google.
But I actually decided on my 26th birthday
to start my own company. I call it "Joie de
Vivre" which is a very impractical name for
a company, hard to spell, hard to pronounce.
Most people in America don't know what it
means. Even if they did know what it means
they wouldn't know how to live it. [laughs]
But it's about joy of life and I said that's
what I was looking for. I want joy of life
for myself, I would like to create an environment
where my employees have that, and I love to
provide that to our customers too.
So the first, and as Meng said, I had no hotel
experience. I understand real estate development
a little bit, but I didn't understand hotels.
So I bought this motel in the Tenderloin in
San Francisco. Now I'm not from a wealthy
family. Anybody from like Southern California
area at all? A few of you, so Long Beach Poly
High School, so I mean this is, I was not
from Beverly Hills. I did not have a bunch
of money in my pocket. So I went out and I
raised a million dollars from people I went
to college and from business school with and
I bought a motel in San Francisco that was
at the corner of Larkin and Eddy. We call
that the "Gateway to the Tenderloin" [laughs].
I call it a good place to go for a run, not
for a walk. [laughs]
[laughter]
But also it was quite well known because it
was called the Caravan Lodge and the Caravan
Lodge was the place that you walked into the
lobby and you saw the nightly rates posted
$49 a night, and then in a slightly smaller
font in the lobby for everyone to see, it
just said "$20 an hour". [laughs] It was a
pay by the hour motel, what we call a "no
tell motel" where people went on their lunch
hour.
So I bought it, had to get rid of Vinnie and
his girls, our biggest corporate account.
[laughs]
[laughter]
And decided to create a Rock and Roll hotel.
And at age 26 the idea of having all these
rock and rollers staying with me in my hotel
sounded like a cool idea. And who else was
gonna stay at a broken down 1950s motel in
the ghetto? Did have bus parking, very important
for [laughs] bands; they like the bus parking.
And the Phoenix, which is what I named it,
became sort of a hit pretty quickly and it
still is. It's a funky place. A lot of the
people you see on the screen here started
staying there and what it taught me pretty
quickly in the boutique hotel business is,
it's not you are what you eat, it's you are
where you sleep.
And let me explain that, you are where you
sleep 'cause this is actually something I
started talking about 24 years ago and when
I started talking about this in the hotel
business they thought I was absolutely nuts
and now it's like the way the world looks
at things because we don't actually -- we
buy products that are a representation of
ourselves. I mean that's just how we buy products.
And we buy them not so much based on our demographics
but more based upon our psychographics.
Let me explain what I mean. Every time we
create a hotel, we actually imagine a magazine
that defines the personality of the hotel.
And the reason we do that is because it's
a really helpful, holistic way of imagining
how to create a holistic product and a personality
that we can all sort of understand what it
is.
So that first hotel, the Phoenix, was based
upon Rolling Stone Magazine. We knew it was
gonna be a rock and roll hotel, came up with
five adjectives that defined Rolling Stone:
funky, irreverent, adventurous, cool, and
young at heart. And everything we did in creating
the hotel -- from the art we chose to the
staff we chose -- we chose funky, irreverent
staff, to the uniforms they wore or they didn't
wear because if they're funky and irreverent
they never wore their uniforms. [laughs] So
to this kind of services and amenities we
offered, it all had to come back to those
five adjectives.
But the miracle in this was not that it helped
create a very interesting hotel. The miracle
is about a year into it when I started to
see who were our biggest advocates, our evangelists,
the people who were going out the telling
their friends about it, I started to realize
that what was common about them was they would
use these five adjectives to describe themselves.
So it was like the hotel was a mirror for
the aspirations of the customer. Does that
make sense?
So I call this "creating an identity refreshment".
If someone checks into the Phoenix and three
days later they check out and they feel a
little bit more funky, irreverent, and adventurous,
we have created more than just a lodging experience,
we have created an identity refreshment.
Now the problem is if you are like my mom
and you're not funky, irreverent, or adventurous
[laughs], then we may have not created the
right identity refreshment for you. So that's
why we have 35 different hotels. We're the
second largest boutique hotelier in the U.S.
now. So I created a hotel for my mom which
was the Hotel Rex in the Union Square area
based upon New Yorker Magazine. The five adjectives
were: clever, literate, artistic, worldly,
and sophisticated.
Then there is this hotel, that hotel up there.
Some of you actually may have even stayed
there. Any of you ever stay at the Hotel Avante?
A few of you, yes. Well let me say Google
should buy this hotel [laughs]
[laughter]
12,000 room nights a year. That hotel gets
12,000 room nights from Google every year.
Do the math on a 91 room hotel, 365 days year.
You know that Google should buy the hotel
because they pretty much, it's almost all
Google people there.
[laughter]
And there are other hotels closer to the Googleplex
here than the Avante. But why does Google
put people up there? If you drive by it, I
mean it's not much to look at. It looks like
some 1982 garden apartment building. But when
you go inside, it's got a little bit of a
cool, I mean in the Valley I mean how many
interesting hotels are there? Not a whole
lot. So it's more interesting than most hotels.
But what we really found was -- in the year
2000 when we created this hotel, which was
two years after you guys started, we decided
to use Wired Magazine. And if you wanna know
the five adjectives we used to define Wired
-- we used to then to create the Avante they
were: smart, techie, creative, visionary,
and iconoclastic. Do those describe Google?
Smart --
[laughter]
techie, creative, visionary, and iconoclastic.
We did that in the year 2000; we'd never heard
of Google, we didn't know who Google was.
Luckily I have a handful of venture capitalist
friends, private equity friends, who in 2001
said, "Look at this little company with the
G in Mountain View. They would be a great
corporate account for your hotel." And we
actually reached out to you in 2001, and you
started -- you as a company -- started using
the hotel soon after that and there was a
great fit because the identity refreshment
we were creating for Google visitors was a
good fit for how Google saw themselves.
Then up in San Francisco, for those of you
who are occasionally up in San Francisco and
at your office, we have a hotel right near
your office in San Francisco, the Hotel Vitale.
Anybody ever been there or seen it, Americana
restaurant there too? This was a hotel that
we opened six years ago and started the process
of trying to build it 13 years ago.
What I believed was that there was a customer
out there who is what I would call post W,
pre-Four Seasons. And what I mean by that
[laughs] is they've sort of outgrown the sort
of narcissistic, hedonistic, you have to wear
black to walk through the lobby kind of boutique
hotel. Have you ever been to one of those
before and felt maybe out of place? Well I
do because I'm old. [laughs]
But they weren't ready for their parents'
version of luxury if their parents even had
a version of luxury. They didn't wanna like
old school, traditional luxury. And we call
these people "bourgeois bohemians" or as David
Brooks called them "bo-bos". [laughs] So if
you like the Hotel Vitale, you are a bo-bo
[laughs].
So it was Dwell Magazine, a modern design
magazine meets Real Simple. The five adjectives
were: fresh, natural, nurturing, modern, and
urbane. And since this hotel opened six years
ago, by far off the charts the most successful
luxury hotel in San Francisco, in terms of
occupancy rate 10 points higher than the Four
Seasons, The Ritz, The St. Regis, The Mandarin,
The W.
So by year 2000, we had 20 hotels. Let me
take a step back again. By year 2000, we had
20 hotels around the Bay Area. We were the
largest hotelier in the Bay Area and all of
our hotels were in the Bay Area. And that
was a great thing, in year 2000 to be the
biggest Bay Area hotelier was quite a big
thing because that was -- the dot com boom
was still, in the year 2000 it was sort of
just about to fall off, but it was still a
pretty heady time.
When people ask me -- I go and give talks
at Harvard Business School and Stanford Business
School every year -- and they ask me to bring
my business model and show the business model,
I bring them this and they all laugh and say,
"Oh no, show us your real business model."
And I say, "No this is actually it."
And let me explain this for a moment because
I think it really actually describes Google
in a big way. This is based upon the premise
that, it actually goes back to a theory from
the Harvard Business School called the Service
Profit Chain which was based upon the premise
empirically, they were able to show, these
three Harvard Business School professors that
service oriented companies that create a great
culture, a compelling culture that is far
and away better than their competitors are
able to create happier, more engaged employees
-- point number two on the heart -- which
leads to typically more loyal customers -- point
number three on the heart -- which leads to
point number four on the heart, a profitable
and sustainable business. So it's like a virtuous
circle.
In 1997, when we were 10 years old as a company
and we had 13 hotels at that point and we
were growing very fast, it was apparent to
me that if we were not gonna actually start
investing in culture, and we had invested
in culture, but we needed to do it a lot more
consciously. And so we brought in two executives
from Southwest Airlines, a company that we
have modeled ourselves on at many times, and
we said for a three day retreat, "Teach us
about Southwest." We bought a book called
"Nuts"; it's a book about Southwest's culture
from 1997 so it's an old book at this point.
And what we learned about Southwest is that
one of Southwest's number one competitive
advantages is from a cultural perspective,
they were so much more successful in terms
of the culture they created for their employees
and as they got bigger, their culture got
stronger. Very important for Google 'cause
this is a very powerful culture here, but
as Google gets bigger, how does the culture
get stronger? That's what we wanted to learn
from Southwest.
And ultimately, this is what we learned and
we put it in the form of a heart. Even though
Southwest Airlines actually has a heart in
their logo and you know what their stock ticker
symbol is? LUV, from Dallas no less, I mean,
like these Texans actually LUV, I mean would
have, that's because of Love Field there,
but long story short is they didn't have,
they'd never put the idea of this business
model in the form of a heart.
We did that at Joie de Vivre partly because
at that point we had 1,000 employees or just
under 1,000 employees and about half of them
have English as a second language and we just
wanted to make sure that our housekeeping
staff who had never had, some of them had
never had a formal education, could understand
the concept of our business model. So this
was it.
I call this Karmic capitalism because I think
what goes around comes around when it comes
to business. Sometimes it takes a long time,
for like Bernie Madoff, it took a really long
time. But I think this is very true that in
the long run, especially in a more transparent
world -- which the Internet has allowed -- is
that Karmic capitalism can actually mean that
the better things you're doing in the world
can come back to you as an organization, and
that's what the heart really shows.
Early in 2001, I should have been and we as
a company should have been in a really great
place. I had a book come out that year with
-- Richard Branson wrote the forward to the
book -- it was called, oops what did I do
there? It was called "The Rebel Rules: Daring
to be Yourself in Business".
But by early 2001 things started to look pretty
ugly here in the Bay Area. I don't know how
many of you were here in the Bay Area working
at that time, but between 2001 and 2005, we
all know the Bay Area suffered through a pretty
cataclysmic downturn especially here in the
Valley.
In fact between 2001 and 2005, Silicon Valley
hotels experienced a 53 percent drop in revenues
on average. So imagine if your industry saw
a 53 percent drop in revenues for the industry
for over a four year period, that's pretty
ugly. In San Francisco the drop was 35 percent
over a four year period. And if you remember,
all of our hotels were here in the Bay Area.
This is the worst percentage revenue drop
in the history of American hotels since World
War II.
So I went from bein' the guy on the left [chuckles]
to the guy on the right really, really quickly.
And what I mean by that is -- previously it
looked like we were smart because we had all
of our eggs in the Bay Area basket and quickly
it looked like we were in trouble. And we
were also in trouble because of these guys.
You've all heard the expression "disruptive
innovation." It's actually an expression that's
used quite often in the high tech world about
how Netflix comes along and kills Blockbuster
and you see it in high tech more often than
you do in our industry.
I never expected to be disruptively innovated
but this is what's happened in 2001. Because
in 2001, all of a sudden the way that actually
our customers booked our rooms changed and
they started doing it all online and so there
was an intermediary, which if you're a boutique
hotelier this commoditized approach to actually
booking your hotel room wasn't really the
best way for our customers to understand whether
they were getting the right hotel. And guess
how much we pay in commissions to Expedia?
We pay less now, but back then 2001 how much
do you think we paid?
[pause]
>>voice in audience: [inaudible]
>>Chip Conley: Higher.
>>female in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Chip Conley: Twenty percent, higher.
>>Chip Conley: Now she's the negotiator whoever
she is [laughs].
[laughter]
[pause]
Twenty-five percent.
So if our average room rate in year 2000 was
$200 and, by 2002, it became $160 because
the market fell apart. At $160, if we're paying
a 25 percent commission to Expedia and you
booked on Expedia, we're only seeing $120.
So between this, the dot com bust, the Afghan
war started about that point, and then we
became a fortress, 9/11, I forgot about 9/11,
yeah. After 9/11 do people wanna jump on a
plane? No. Do people travel a lot? No. Then
the economy soured. Did people wanna spend
money? No. Afghani war starts. We have a fortress
America perspective, it's hard to immigrate
or even just to visit the U.S. from outside,
SARS, SARS happened 2002, 2003. Ninety percent
drop in Asian travel over a 10 month period.
The number one location that Asians travel
to in the U.S. as of that time was the Bay
Area.
So that stopped, and then what else happened?
Oh, oh, so we're named Joie de Vivre. Remember
in 2003 the Iraqi War? Remember the Iraqi
War, during the Iraqi war we decided to go
to war with Iraq and then there was one country
in the world that we went to war with politically
or diplomatically and they're in Europe and
we started boycotting their products. Who?
France. And we stopped eating French fries,
remember that, what do we call them?
>>audience: Freedom fries.
>>Chip Conley: So Americans started boycotting
French companies. What's the name of my company?
[laughter]
I was getting letters from [chuckles] Orange
County and Danville and [laughs] all these
hotbeds of conservatism and they would write
me and say, "We're boycotting Joie de Vivre
because we're boycotting all French companies."
And I would write them back and I'd say, "I'm
sorry. We're not a French company. We're based
in San Francisco." And they would write back
and they would say, "Oh that's worse." [laughs]
[laughter]
So like San Francisco's left of Paris.
So long story short, we were in trouble. We
had about 1,000 employees at that point; I
didn't know how I was going to make payroll
in a couple months. And so I ended up in the
Borders Bookstore at the corner of Post and
Powell at Union Square, around the corner
from our office on a lunch hour looking for
a clue. I initially was looking for a business
book, I was sort of going back to my business
roots as a business school MBA from Stanford
and I said, "I wanna find a business book."
But within three minutes inside the bookstore
[chuckles], I actually realized I didn't need
a business book I needed a self help book
and so I ended up in the self help section
of the bookstore and I found a psychology
book. I only took one psychology class in
college.
Any of you ever go to Stanford, anybody go
to Stanford? There's a professor named Professor
Zimbardo, sort of famous, and that was the
one class. I took Professor Zimbardo's Psychology
101 class. The one thing I remembered from
my psychology class in college was Abraham
Maslow because he had sort of a positive perspective
on the human condition as opposed to a negative
perspective. In fact you've probably heard
a quote from him. He once said to the psychology
profession in the 1940s, and you've heard
this, "If the only tool you have is a hammer,
everything starts to look like a --
>>audience: nail.
>>Chip Conley: That was Abe Maslow. And he
said it because what he said was that the
psychology community had gotten so used to
actually studying people in trouble, that
they just assumed that everybody as humans
had lots of troubles and that their job as
psychologists was to find the troubles. And
that sort of what consultants do, that's what
a lot of people do in life. But the reality
is it goes back to where are we paying our
attention? What Maslow said is, "Let's pay
our attention to people who are fulfilled.
Let's actually -- what if we studied a thousand
people who are actually in a better place
in life and we studied their best practices
in the human condition as opposed to the worst
practices? And what if we could then teach
it to other people?" And that's what he did
in the 1940s and he created what he's famous
for which is Maslow's hierarchy of needs.
Now, oops, I'm not gonna tell you whether
this -- there's problems with this model and
I'm not gonna, and during the Q and A we can
talk about it. It's not perfect, but it's
pretty famous for actually helping the psychology
industry and profession start rethinking the
idea of best practices versus worst practices.
What Maslow was able to show was that people
who are actually fulfilled in life have their
basic physiological needs met. We have four
basic needs each of us needs no matter where
we are in the planet, what are they? [laughs]
There's a fifth need that you think everybody
has to have, that is not absolutely required.
Ask a nun.
[laughter]
But it's water, food, air, and sleep. You
have to have it. You cannot actually live
for very long without those four no matter
who you are and where you live. But that's
not the purpose of life. And above that becomes
your safety needs. Once those needs are partially
met, you go to your safety needs, your social
belonging needs, your esteem needs, and at
the top of the pyramid Abraham Maslow, and
I swear he was not from Mill Valley hanging
out in a hot tub. He was a guy from Brooklyn.
[laughs] He was not like sort of a like a
crunchy sort of granola head. He basically
said at the top of the pyramid, people who
are in the fulfilled state are self actualized.
And what he meant by that is that they're
being all they can be, to steal a phrase from
the U.S. Army who actually stole that from
Maslow. Being all you can be. He said, "People
who are in life in their best place in life
and they feel like 'I'm just being all I can
be. I feel like I'm in a place in my life
that just feels like this is why I'm here
on earth.'" When you're in that state, you're
at sort of the peak of the pyramid and you
would have peak experiences at that time.
And when someone has a peak experience, they
tend to lose track of time, they basically
sort of become one with the world.
Now we don't, for most of us, this doesn't
happen for extended periods of time. You have
these moments of peak experiences, they're
moments and they don't have to happen at work.
I mean most of them probably don't happen
in work. But I'm reading this book, I actually
sat for four hours at the bookstore [chuckles].
I finally said, "Okay I can afford the book."
I didn't take a salary for three and a half
years during this time. I mean I went for
three and a half years without a salary because
all of our senior executives had to take major,
major cuts in pay in order for us to get through
the time without doing any layoffs because
we just didn't wanna do layoffs.
So I asked myself as I was reading this book
and I took it home and the next couple weeks
I said, "Well if individuals, if we as humans
can actually be self actualized, why couldn't
a company be self actualized? Because a company's
just a collection of humans." It's an interesting
question to ask.
So I went back to my senior execs and I said,
"Let's look at how we would apply the hierarchy
of needs to a hotel guest experience. And
we did. And so this is the hotel guest experience.
And right here on the pyramid, if you're staying
at Motel 6 you sort of, that's all you expect,
maybe that and the lights being turned on,
because at the bottom of the pyramid when
you're actually not spending a lot of money,
you do not expect a lot. But if you're staying
at the Four Seasons, you're expecting a lot
more.
So what we started to see is that hey Maslow's
hierarchy of needs, there's a hierarchy of
needs for everybody, we all have hierarchies
of needs. And we started to say, "Well how
do we apply this to our three most important
stake holders in the company?"
We took the five level hierarchy of needs
and we turned it into three levels 'cause
there's really three key themes in life. There
are really three key themes in life. There's
survival, which is your physiological and
safety needs. There's success or being, there's
succeeding which is your social belonging
and your esteem needs. And at the top of the
pyramid, there's this thing called transformation,
when you are feeling self actualized.
So I'm gonna quickly go through these using
this as the model, our three key constituencies
and how we apply this to our three key stakeholders
or constituencies.
This is the employee pyramid. I think that
Google does this very well frankly. In fact,
in the book I actually talk a little bit about
Google. The base of the pyramid is money.
Now that doesn't mean that there aren't CEO's
making $50 million a year who are sort of
feeling like it's a higher need too. But the
baseline is money or our compensation package
or in Google's case with the full range of
what you have as additional perks, it's all
of that. It's the package of compensation
that makes you feel like you're either well
compensated or not. It's not just your salary.
That's where survival comes from, that's where
you get sort of base motivation.
But the reality is that most people, most
people do not leave their job because of money
alone. It's not the number one reason. It's
fourth place. It's the fourth most likely
reason why a person leaves their job. In the
Valley, it's the fifth. I know you may not
believe that [laughs] like everybody in the
Valley is just only interested in money. No.
It's the, in the valley it's the fifth most
likely reason a person leaves their job based
upon surveys here.
So what's the number one reason people leave
their job?
[pause]
>>female in audience: [unintelligible]
Their boss. Oh man you're so stupid, you're
so smart. It is. That was good. Exactly.
So Gallup did a survey and Marcus Buckingham
wrote a book about it -- what was that -- "First,
Break All the Rules" and he basically showed
that the number one reason people leave their
work, they join a company but they leave their
boss. So they join a company and leave their
boss.
So this part of the pyramid, feeling recognized,
when you actually feel recognized by your
boss, by your peers, by the organization,
you're seen for who you are, you have a career
track, you have the sense that you are appreciated
and recognized for what your skill set is.
When that's happening, you're more likely
to be loyal 'cause you're loyal to other humans.
You're maybe loyal to the company too, but
generally speaking at the end of the day,
you're loyal to other people. That's the second
level of the pyramid.
But at the top of the pyramid is this idea
of meaning and I wanna come back and show
you something that we talked about earlier.
Take a look right over here on this line here:
job, career, calling. When you actually are
focused on your money and that's your predominant
thing you're focusing on, it's a job. When
you're focused on your career, it's typically
focused on recognition, your career path,
how you're being recognized, how you're feeling
successful.
At the top of the pyramid, when you actually
have a sense of meaning in what you're doing
and what the organization does, you actually
are likely to be living a calling. And the
big difference between the two lower levels
here and the top level is external motivation;
it's like a bartering thing. The company gives
you job and recognition and you give something
in return. But when you get to the top of
the pyramid you're actually tapping into internal
motivation. And any organization that has
actually tapped into internal motivation as
opposed to external motivation has created
mojo, has created the kind of magic that can
last a long time.
So now some of you may say, "Well that sounds
like a lot of great theory -- but put it into
practice." Well I have. We have 3500 employees
today, 1300 of our employees clean toilets
for a living. How do you create an experience
of a calling in cleaning a toilet? You guys
are smart. That's the kind of question that
Google would ask in an interview, right? [laughs]
I mean I've heard about the interviews you
do here. They're pretty intense.
[pause]
So answer that one for me, how does someone
live a calling cleaning toilets for a living?
[pause]
>>female in audience: You tap into their desire
to help [unintelligible]
>>Chip Conley: What she said was when you
tap into their interest and ability to help
people to have a great experience in the hotel.
Absolutely. The bottom line is you cannot
help someone live a calling by focusing on
their task. And this has been proven in hospitals.
Fascinating survey five years ago: American
hospitals, they looked at hospitals across
America and they looked at the variables that
create the most successful hospitals. They
looked at how smart are the doctors, what
schools did they come from, what's the insurance
programs they have, where are the hospitals
located, are they in affluent areas, etcetera,
etcetera, what kind of specialties are there.
The number one indicator and variable for
successful hospitals in America was
[pause]
how happy are the nurses.
Number one; off the charts way above number
two.
So then they said, "Well what is it that makes
happy nurses?" And what they found is that
nurses who think of their work as a job have
a tendency to think of it as a checklist of
32 things they have to do. And those nurses
who really love what they're doing and are
living their calling are focused on the purpose
of what they're doing and the impact it has
on, in this case, patients. For our housekeeping
staff, it's our customers.
So if you wanna help people move up the pyramid,
you have to figure out how to link the impact
on customer with the employee. So we do a
variety of things, Chapter 6 in the book is
all about meaning, talked about some of them.
But we come up with all of these ways for
our housekeeping staff to get connected face
to face with our guests and to hear stories.
We actually bring guests who are, guests of
the hotel into a housekeeping summit where
we bring all our housekeepers together and
we have them tell stories.
And we had a woman once come in and tell a
story about she's from Denver, she actually
had come back to San Francisco, she'd come
into San Francisco regularly, she had two
new twins and she was a single mother, and
long story short is she got fired. And she
was on her way walking to the roof of the
hotel to jump off when one of the housekeepers
who had known her for a long time, because
this woman had been staying at our hotel for
four years, actually could see she was crying
and she was walking up the roof, walking up
the stairs to the roof. She stopped her, it
was about 11:30 and she said, "Would you like
to have lunch with me and the rest of the
housekeeping staff?" And in fact the woman
said, "Okay." And they had lunch in her room,
in her guest room, they brought other lumpia,
primarily Filipino staff and they brought
lumpia and all their favorite sort of Filipino
foods, they were having a lunch together anyways.
And this woman didn't jump off the roof and
this woman actually came back and told that
story to 600 housekeepers on our staff. So
creating that impact, understanding  helping
our housekeeping staff understand that they're
not just in the business of cleaning toilets
and that purpose is much bigger than that
is helpful.
Let's move on to the customer pyramid. So
I wanna make sure we have some time for Q
and A.
Customer pyramid. The baseline for customers,
the survival need for customers is, "Please
meet my expectations," because we are expectations
machines as humans. We wake up in the morning
and we already have like 42 expectations in
our head; that's just how it works. So in
fact that's true, I mean like you've bought
a car before and then you've had buyer's remorse.
So expectations here, reality here, the difference
is disappointment. You've gone on a honeymoon,
expectations here, [laughs] reality here,
[laughs] divorce, I don't know. The fact is
that's how our minds work and that's how customers
are. And the more we're spending as a customer,
as a Four Seasons customer, our expectations
are higher than as a Motel 6 customer.
So first of all, we have to meet the expectations
to even get on the pyramid. If you're not
even meeting the expectations of the customer,
you didn't even make it on the pyramid. But
the fact is if this is all you're providing
your customers is satisfaction, you're in
trouble, you are GM, although GM's coming
back finally, or Sears or Montgomery Ward
or someone from the last century who thought
that what's the most important thing for a
company to do is to create customer satisfaction.
And yet 80 percent of customers who are satisfied
defect because of the Internet, because of
the choices. Because in the past, we didn't
think we had choices, we now do.
So meeting desires is a step above that. But
the most important thing, one of the questions
we ask within the company is for each of our
hotels is, "What's the expectations of our
customers and what's the desires?" There can
be a difference and then figuring out what
the difference there is an important question.
Top of the pyramid though is where a customer
says, "Wow! They thought of something I hadn't
even imagined." It's when a customer says,
"They thought of things for me that I didn't
have to ask for." And companies that do this
well are companies that actually [laughs]
have very evangelical customers. Google has
evangelical customers. I see a lot of Apples
out here in the audience, very evangelical
customers. You wanna ask yourself, "Who are
the companies out there who have evangelical
customers?" They're companies generally that
have actually thought about what the customer
needs and have figured out what the customer
wants and needs before the customer even figured
it out themselves.
There are four key ways to do this and if
somebody wants to ask a question about it
I'll tell you what those four ways are during
the Q and A 'cause I wanna keep goin' and
they're in the book too.
But there's a way to actually mind read your
customers and to get there before they do.
So finally, last slide related to the three
stakeholders. This is the investor slide,
I'll spend very little time on this. But the
survival need for investors is just being
what I call "transactional alignment" which
means that the entrepreneur or the company
and their investors are on the same page,
same business plan, and that's the basic.
That they're just trying to make sure that
they are -- understand how we define success.
The next level above that is the relationship
alignment. That's what Warren Buffett, Warren
Buffet once said that "Dumb investors focus
on the glass of milk," this is the glass of
milk. "Smart investors focus on the cow."
[laughs] The relationship. So the investor
focuses on the cow, the company or the entrepreneur
is the cow.
And then investors who are self actualized
and I know that sounds like an oxymoron because
are investor's human? That's the first question
to ask. This is a human hierarchy of needs
and we're trying to apply it to investors.
But when you have an investor who actually
thinks of their investing as a legacy, it's
at the top of the pyramid.
This is all three pyramids together: the employee
pyramid, customer pyramid, the investor pyramid.
There's something in between. There's something
that goes in between, you saw it earlier.
What is it?
[pause]
It's in inverted pyramid shape.
>>voice in audience: [inaudible]
[pause]
Yeah, the heart.
Strangely enough, in 1997 we created the customer
service heart. 2002, 2003 at the depth of
the downturn, the dot com bust, we created
the peak pyramid. When we first did this,
I had no clue that the heart went in the middle.
For a year, I didn't even figure it out.
And then I was giving a talk at one point,
because this, we tripled in size during the
dot com bust, Joie de Vivre went from $80
million dollar a year company to a $220 million
dollar a year company during the worst of
times because of this model.
So I was giving a speech and someone said
to me, a woman in the back of the room kept
raising her hands, because the middle of the
pyramid had nothing in it. And she kept saying,
"The heart, the heart, the heart." I had no
idea what she was talking about. And she said,
"Idiot! [laughs] Chip, you're an idiot!! [laughs]
Put the heart in the middle." And she was
right. And here's the part that's interesting
[laughter]
point number one on the heart is about culture,
but remember point number two on the heart
is enthusiastic staff, it's right next to
the employee pyramid. Point number three on
the heart strong customer loyalty is right
next to the customer pyramid. And point number
four on the heart, maintaining a profitable
and sustainable business, right next to the
investor pyramid.
So here's the cheesy part of my presentation
or maybe my whole presentation's cheesy, the
heart beats.
>>audience: Ahhh.
>>Chip Conley: Ahh. Yeah.
[applause]
So what's the point of the heart beating?
The heart beating actually means this business
model is what brings these three pyramids
together. If you're on Southwest Airlines,
I mean they're not perfect but I'm just using
them as an example today, and you actually
see a flight attendant who is living his or
her calling and making you feel good as a
customer, the truth is that experience of
having somebody who's enthusiastic helps you
move up your pyramid as a customer. And if
you've moving up your pyramid as a customer,
more likely the investors are moving up their
pyramid too.
[pause]
Here's a bunch of companies that consciously
use Maslow. I have put Google here because
I think you do, I don't know that for sure,
but I have had a couple conversations with
people who work here who've actually told
me that there's a Maslovian element to Google.
But some of these others companies literally
have used Maslow. Apple used Maslow in creating
their retail stores. Ron Johnson, head of
retail for Apple worldwide -- I went to college
with him. He told me about this. Harley Davidson,
the guy who actually helped remake Harley
Davidson in the 1980s was someone who studied
with Abe Maslow. Tony Hsieh at Zappos. Tony
wrote the forward for my book, complete Maslowmania
at Zappos. [laughs] So there's a lotta companies
that use it.
This is the book and the basic premise is
that if you create peak experiences for your
key stakeholders, you'll be able to create
peak performance for your organization. And
it's really simple. It just comes back to
the idea that at the base of the pyramid,
it's all about survival. And especially in
a recession the tendency is for us all, whether
we're an employee, whether we're a customer,
whether we're an investor, we all sort of
go back to survival mode.
But survival mode is a commodity and when
you move up the pyramid, you're moving from
commodity to differentiation, to deep loyalty.
And at the end of the day in business, it
really is all about deep loyalty, whether
it's deep loyalty of an employee through living
a calling with the company, whether it's the
deep loyalty of a customer being an evangelist,
or whether it's the deep loyalty of an investor
who's looking at the investment as a legacy
and a long term investment as opposed to just
a wham bam thank you m'am kind of investor.
Which excuse the expression, but that's how
most investors on Wall Street are.
So I hope you'll all seek the peak. This is
a little bit more information on Joie de Vivre,
a little bit more information on me that my
publisher required me to come up with. [chuckles]
And then for those of you who really wanna
understand a little bit more about peak and
some of the peak organization opportunities
of what we do, this is the Website for a lot
of companies now that are actually using peak
as a model for their company.
So thank you. I'm gonna open up for questions
and answers now. So thank you very much.
[applause]
So questions, anybody. Go for it. Yes.
>>female #1: So I used to teach high school
students and I used to be able to say very
freely I love my school and kids 'cause I
love them and now I'm here at Google and I
teach engineers leadership
>>Chip Conley: Um-hum.
>>female #1: so how do I talk about this idea
of like love of customer, of employee, of
investor of stakeholders without sounding
like --
>>Chip Conley: Yeah.
>>female #1: I don't know what the right word
is but --
>>Chip Conley: Like a granola head.
>>female #1: Yeah, or like you're doing this
[ ] or like there's babies or you know --
>>Chip Conley: Well, so what I've done, so
let me tell ya, Meng and I are gonna be next
week with a bunch of, a lot of CEO's of companies,
a lot of senior executives in companies and
some academics. What's great about today versus
say 10 or 15 years ago is there is an awful
lot of empirical evidence today that a love
based culture, that's going too strong, I
would rarely use that phrase, I would use
a stakeholder driven model to make it sound
a little bit more empirical.
That model has been proven to actually be
very effective for both driving shareholder
returns but also creating a legacy in an organization
such that it has long term viability.
So there's a book called "Firms of Endearment"
which is a terrible name for a book [laughs]
but "Firms of Endearment" actually sort of
went toe to toe with "Good to Great", Jim
Collins' book and actually studied a bunch
of companies comparing them with the Good
to Great companies. And these Firms of Endearment
companies were companies that actually took
a stakeholder love approach to their key constituencies
and stakeholders and they were able to show
over a 10 year period that the actual returns
on the stock market were much better.
So I would say language is important, I would
say love based, using the word "love" is a
cautionary word I would use. I would say there's
other ways you can present it. But in terms
of those who actually wanna say, "Well I don't
believe in that, I believe that business is
all about transactions."
So this is really the difference between at
the base of the pyramid, it's all about transactions
and at the top of the pyramid, it's about
transformation. And there are times in business
when it is all about transactions. I'm not
saying that that's not true -- it is. There
are times when the transactions are what define
the business. And yet over the course of the
long run, transactions are a commodity, but
transformation is actually something that
actually shifts something in a fundamental
way. And that's ultimately what Google is
about. I mean so for you, you have a mission
statement and a culture that's sort of built
on that so it's easier for you to maybe get
your fellow employees to sort of see the importance
of that.
One thing that's been very gratifying for
me is the two industries -- so I was saying
this to my friend Dan who's one of your smart
guys here and I've known a long time, that
the two industries that have shown the most
interest in peaks since they came out are
the health care industry and financial services.
Health care because many people got into health
care for the top of the pyramid, for the meaning
and the calling, and they don't feel it anymore.
And health care's going through a major transformation
and it needs to rethink how they actually
operate. And the other is financial service.
And financial services, as an industry, is
a transactional industry. And yet there are
huge, huge companies out there who are now
hiring us to go out and remake their whole
program on retirement and their program on
how they help their employees move from living
a transactional culture to more of a long
term transformational culture.
So I do think there's enough shifts out there
in the business world and in the academic
business world where professors -- when I
was in Stanford Business School they had couple
classes on relationships; today they have
lots and they have a class on happiness at
Stanford Business School now. I mean it's
a class all about happiness, believing that
happiness is the number one thing that actually
creates success in business. Well okay, we
didn't have that in 1984. So -- what else?
Yes.
>>female #2: So when you were going through
your slides, the slide that has [unintelligible]
slide --
>>Chip Conley: Um-hum.
>>female #2: where you had the expectations
--
>>Chip Conley: That's [unintelligible]
>>female #2: [unintelligible] and then the.
So this kind of looks a bit to me like how
our employees kind of see our company.
>>Chip Conley: This is -- okay.
>>female #2: So this resonated, when I saw
this I was like oh this is kind of like how
I think in a lot of ways especially since
we've become a branded kind of company -- people
come into the culture with certain expectations,
it's less of a how and I don't wanna paint
like a dark picture because this place is
amazing, I love this place.
>>Chip Conley: And you've been here for a
while?
>>female #2: Yes.
>>Chip Conley: [laughs] Okay.
>>female #2: But at the same time I do think
that people come in sometimes with less of
an attitude of not so much what can I do for
my country, but what can my country do for
me?
>>Chip Conley: Right.
>>female #2: So I'm just wondering how does
this actually work when your employees are
more like customers I think in a lot of ways?
>>Chip Conley: Well, I mean so the employee
-- there's a bit of a connection here. When
employees sort of think of their work as a
job and they're just punching in and punching
out and the question is, "What am I getting
from my job" as opposed to "What am I becoming
as a result of my work?" Let me say that again.
It's a very important thing to consider when
you're doing your work. Most of us in our
work have a tendency to think of "what are
we getting from our job?" as opposed to "What
am I becoming as a result of my work?"
Now when people think that way, if you think
that way, you're probably gonna be, "What
am I getting from my job?" It's very expedient.
It's like okay, "I wanna make money, I wanna
do well, what can we do" potentially they
may also think sort of bottom of the pyramid
with respect to the customer experience.
I think one of the things that I would just
offer here is -- the company's 13 years old
now, 12 or 13 years old. So the question is
how does Google on a regular basis renew its
relationship with revolution? [laughs] How
does the organization as it gets larger renew
its ability to just feel like it is meant
to be a revolutionary, it's meant to actually
constantly be striving for this at the top
of the pyramid?
I don't work here so I can't tell you. From
the outside it feels like you do. It feels
like there's an awful lot of time, energy,
and money being poured into ventures that
don't necessarily have an ROI attached to
them, but are really purposed for the sake
of actually trying to create something new
and innovative that's gonna actually build
a better relationship with the customer and
can potentially be monetized into something
else in the future. But maybe not. If I'm
wrong, if I'm wrong on that, then that's where
you need to get back to. But I guess your
point is almost a little bit of the hiring
component. How do you actually make sure that
the people coming in are acquainted with that
and then believe that that's part of what
they're here for? Is that right?
[pause]
>>male voice: [unintelligible]
Yeah, okay.
>>female #2: Thanks.
>>Chip Conley: Okay. Yes. We're out of time,
we're out of time, we're out of time. If anybody
has a question feel free to come up and ask
me, please feel free to. And there's I guess
books in the back and sorry to the team who's
coming in now and thanks for having me here.
Bye.
[applause]